bonsoir à tous parsys est impressionnant
de vue d'ici donc je me représente
mireille tanoh fram je suis actuellement
responsable communication dans une
institution de la place et je vais vous
conter un peu mon histoire à travers le
thème le sous thème que j'ai décidé de
développer et que j'ai intitulé 3v du
succès en fait les étapes que j'ai pu
découvrir pour aboutir donc à ce qu'on
appelle le succès et ses trois étapes
vont partir de 2,90 à maintenant donc je
fais un découpage sur trois ans par
rapport à ma vie donc de 90 à 2000 je
pars en france je fais mes études
diplômés de chez diplômés est bon je
passe les détails et je rentre en côte
d'ivoire parce que mon objectif était
vraiment de servir mon pays donc je
rentre premier poste bon salaire cadre
tout de suite vraiment c'était la belle
vie voiture enfin tout ce qu'il fallait
alors moi je pensais que la vie c'était
ça mais au-delà de ça j'avais un malaise
intérieurement j'avais pas confiance en
moi mais je paraissais voilà j'ai essayé
de paraître au lieu d'être et sa durée 9
ans non j'avais des gir côté beaucoup de
succès beaucoup de prix pendant ma
carrière et en 2009
tout bascule je perds mon emploi j'ai
deux enfants donc je me suis abandonnée
abandonné par don par le père des deux
et je me retrouve seul initialement
quand j'ai perdu mon emploi j'étais
plutôt satisfaite parce que pendant la
première partie du vais donc que
j'appelais la vision j'avais découvert
effectivement ce qui pourrait être une
étoile polaire c'est à dire j'avais
découvert cette passion que j'avais pour
les autres aider les autres à se
réaliser à s'accomplir et avoir
confiance en eux pour vraiment servir
l'autre
enfin servir leur environnement et
autres avec leur talent personnel
j'avais découvert ça pendant la première
année et vers la fin de ma première
carrière je me focalisais plus sur ce
sujet là donc c'était plus trop
concentrée même sur mon métier donc
limites quand j'ai perdu mon emploi je
me suis dit ok fallait que ça
reeves parce que j'aurais peut-être pas
eu le courage de me lancer et dans cette
même période j'ai rencontré un homme un
homme un homme de dieu qui en même temps
coach en développement personnel
donc il s'appelle ivan castanou et au
sortir d'une réunion qu'il a animée il a
abordé un thème qui m'a interpellé
trouver son identité
et puis de découvrir son potentiel pour
pouvoir vraiment le réaliser et trouver
véritablement l'épanouissement auquel on
aspire tous et depuis ce jour là les
choses se sont bousculées dans ma tête
je me suis dit enfin développement
personnel qu'est ce que c'est en fait je
ne savais pas que c'est ce que j'avais
commencé à manifester depuis voilà parce
que c'est vrai que c'était pareil
c'était bizarre c'était paradoxal parce
que en même temps que je n'avais pas
confiance en moi mais j'arrivais à
motiver les autres et j'étais quelqu'un
de très optimiste pour la petite
histoire lorsque j'étais étudiante en
france je me suis dit je ne viens pas en
france pour faire des petits boulots ça
m'intéresse pas pas que je les derniers
que non mais parce que je veux remplir
mon cv
parce qu'une fois j'ai fait un entretien
pour un stage qui m'intéressait le roc
de le recruteur m'a dit c'est vrai vous
pouvez avoir le potentiel mais vous
n'avez pas d'expérience et ça ça m'a
choqué je ne dis plus jamais je ne
permettrai à quelqu'un de me dire ça
alors je me suis dit je fais et j'ai
fait j'ai travaillé en france à air
france comment dans les grandes
entreprises
parce que je m'étais mis en tête que
j'étais pas venu ici pour rester pour
avoir les papiers éternellement je te
suis allé à la faveur de l'année blanche
et donc c'était une opportunité unique
pardon une opportunité pour moi de
découvrir autre chose
et effectivement j'ai fait vraiment une
bonne carrière bonnes études tout ça et
quand je suis rentré et que j'ai perdu
mon emploi et que j'ai entendu parler de
développement personnel je me suis dit
tiens
est ce que c'est parce que j'avais
commencé à développer sans le savoir
bon ok je perds mon emploi donc vu que
j'étais déjà à fond dans le sujet
j'avais commencé à écrire des projets je
me dis bon j'avais un peu de ressources
c'est l'opportunité pour moi je lance
mes projets alain c'est là que je rentre
dans le 2ème vais donc la vallée alors
je lance dans les jeux lance des projets
j'investis échec je perds tout je me
retrouve sans ressources
je ma fille qui est là qui a 11 ans
aujourd'hui l'afer a démarré à la quand
elle avait 6 ou 7 ans mon deuxième mot
monfils avait deux ans sans ressources
parce que du jour au lendemain je perds
tout
alors je suis abandonnée du pardon vous
imaginez un peu ce qui se dit autour de
nous l'humiliation les moqueries tout ça
mais je vous assure c'est vrai que dans
une première phase j'étais révolté je me
suis dit non c'est pas possible ça peut
pas m'arriver à moi qu'est ce que je
vais devenir et tout qu'est ce que les
autres vont penser et cetera et puis
après je me suis dit non en fait c'est
peut-être une opportunité de mieux
cerner mon projet est de mieux affiner
ma vision dont je vais me focaliser sur
le développement personnel
alors j'ai commencé à faire des
recherches j'ai commencé à écrire des
articles sur facebook j'étais très
adepte de facebook à cette époque là
comme le précédera orateurs alors
j'étais j'écrivais des articles et je
coachais des gens sur facebook
mais pendant que je coachais des gens
sur facebook j'avais rien à manger chez
moi pendant que je côtoie des gens sur
facebook
j'avais peur que mes enfants rentrent de
l'école à midi parce que je ne savais
pas quoi leur dire y avait rien et
pendant que je coache les gens sont sur
facebook
j'avais pas d'eau à la maison mais
malgré tout je m'étais raccrocher à
cette vision parce que je vais prouver
mon étoile polaire je me suis dit que
c'est ça qui allait me faire sortir de
cette situation alors je me suis
rapproché j'ai continué j'ai continué
j'ai commencé à écrire des articles et
un jour je reçois un coup de fil de la
chambre de commerce qui m'annonce que
j'ai un courrier du président de la
chambre de commerce
bon pourquoi vous avez eu un prix un
prix de quoi un prix leader du futur ah
bon c'est quoi ce prix en fait c'est
quelqu'un qui vous a proposé par rapport
à tout ce que vous faites u2 mais je
fais quoi je fais rien parce que pour
moi en fait c'était une passion donc
pour moi c'était en fait même c'est un
moyen de surmonter la situation que je
traversais parce que quand je me mettais
dans mon monde développement personnel
plus rien n'existe et autour de moi et
quand j'étais était vraiment abattus et
tout je cherchais quelqu'un à coacher
voilà je cherchais quelqu'un côté quand
je le faisais franchement je me sentais
bien
donc je mais je ne savais pas que s'il y
avait eu un impact mais après j'ai eu
des témoignages comme quand beaucoup de
personnes avait été impacté par mes
écrits
j'ai eu à écrire des articles dans des
journaux réussir en côte d'ivoire et
tout ça je me suis dit enfin le prix
donc effectivement je vais je prends mon
prix quelques temps après l'uemoa et la
chambre de commerce de lens un prix
talents du monde
voilà je postule là j'écris ma vision et
j'ai encore ce prix je dis waouh donc en
fait c'est facile d'avoir des prix il
suffit d'avoir une vision
il n'est pas question de soudoyer qui
que ce soit enfin je parle de faire
l'intéressant il suffit juste d'avoir
une vision et je vous assure que cette
vision déclenché ce qui ce que ça doit
déclencher dans fort de ces deux prix
j'ai repris confiance en moi et j'ai
commencé à coacher des jeunes j'ai
commencé à exercer mon talent donc j'ai
commencé parce que j'ai découvert une
passion parce qu initialement j'ai eu
intéresser son commerce marketing
voilà mais j'ai commencé j'ai découvert
cette passion en ressources humaines
j'ai jamais fait d'études en ressources
humaines mais je me suis surprise à
faire des entretiens dans bush et à
détecter des talents pour la petite
histoire j'avais une amie qu'avait une
agence qui travaillait beaucoup pour un
opérateur de téléphonie et donc elle
faisait beaucoup d'opérations terrain
est bon parlons avec elle elle
connaissait ma passion pour le
développement personnel
elle me demandait de l'aider à faire son
recrutement et j'ai discuté avec un
jeune qui avait un diplôme en géographie
mais bon qui auraient besoin d'argent
donc avait postulé parce que bon juste
parce qu'il fallait qu'il ait de
l'argent je dis bon à la limite si c'est
juste pour l'argent vous ne nous
intéressait pas et j'ai discuté avec eux
pour ça avec lui pardon pour comprendre
un peu qu'elle était quelle a été sa
motivation pour faire cette maîtrise en
géographie et me dit ce sont mes parents
qui m'ont poussé à le faire je suis à
eau
ça c'est la même erreur que j'ai à
laquelle j'ai été confronté mais dieu
merci mon tempérament m'a permis de
résister à mes parents parce
qu'effectivement c'était une erreur à la
question et raquettes beaucoup de jeunes
sont malheureusement confronté il ne
s'oriente pas par rapport à leur
potentiel par rapport à l'entourage par
rapport aux parents et dont je discute
avec lui et j'essaie de comprendre un
peu ses motivations
là je détecte en lui le talent pour le
métier effectivement de commercial et
ont discuté tout de suite ils sont une
petite flamme s'allume et on lui me dit
ok je dis bon pour la petite pologne
juste pour ça je vous prend et on verra
ce que ça va donner mais aujourd'hui
c'est quelqu'un qui a arrêté la
géographique
c'est dans les us d'ingénierie
commercial mais pas pour faire plaisir
aux parents mais parce qu'il a trouvé
que c'est un métier qui lui permettait
de le servir l'autre voilà donc c'est un
exemple parmi tant d'autres mais tout ça
je le faisais simplement un par amour je
coachais également les femmes parce que
en plus d'avoir permis non mon emploi
j'ai accumulé ce qu'on appelle les
échecs sentimentaux alors dans le
premier vais donc était la vision
je pensais que c'était une honte et tout
ça mais quand je suis arrivé dans le
2ème vecquée laval et j'ai compris que
dans cette épreuve là en fait je n'avais
pas eu la bonne eu un proche est là le
les bons critères de choix parce
qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup veulent se
marier aujourd'hui moi je dis je suis
célibattante pas célibataire
célibattante j'ai 42 ans
j'ai deux enfants merveilleux que j'ai
élevé seule et aujourd'hui j'ai une
autre façon de conduire ma vie
sentimentale parce que lorsque vous
trouvez votre étoile polaire je vous
assure que toute votre vie tourne tourne
autour de ça même les personnes que vous
fréquentez aujourd'hui je suis arrivé à
un stade c'est vrai que je travaille
pour une institution je tairai le nom
mais très sincèrement mes diplômes ne
m'aurait pas amené là c'est ce talent là
qui m'a conduit là et aujourd'hui j'ai
lu mission qu'un être humain normal seul
ne peut pas faire parce que c'est bon
j'ai pas envie de dire ce que je fais ce
qu'ils veulent veuve qui viennent me
demander mais franchement c'est une
mission qui concerne le pays
vous comprenez mais en deux ans de
l'activité je me suis surprise à faire
ça naturellement comme un poisson dans
l'eau parce que c'est une mission qui
est en rapport direct avec mon étoile
polaire est à dire ma passion pour les
autres à travers les deux le
développement personnel
mais plus les aider vraiment à être et
non plus apparaître
parce que quand vous passez par la
vallée vous découvrez la vie autrement
c'est à dire que les critères de
richesse choses changent pardon avant
dans l'impression qu'on est riche parce
qu'on a de l'argent mais on est ensemble
source
j'ai découvert ma véritable richert
richesse bardon et c'est là que j'ai eu
confiance en moi mais je vous assure
n'ayant pas mangé pendant deux jours je
sortais la tête haute parce que je me
sentais je savais que j'avais quelque
chose à l'essai à ce monde et dont je
suis arrivé depuis 2013 dans cette étape
de la victoire la victoire pas parce que
j'ai est un ange a atteint tous les
objectifs mais parce que mon système de
pensée a changé parce que j'ai commencé
à appliquer ce que j'ai un
parce que je vois les choses
différemment et j'arrive à impacter même
les enfants avec ça parce que pour la
petite histoire nos enfants sont souvent
neuf des victimes de nos parents parce
qu'on ne les aide pas justement à
trouver leur étoile polaire donc
beaucoup de ces enfants là se retrouvent
à un certain âge ne sachant pas ce
qu'ils ont à faire dans la vie ils n'ont
pas de vision or c'est la vision qui
détermine la trajectoire et c'est la
vision qui crée le véritable
épanouissement et comme ils n'ont pas de
vision ils font comme tout le monde et
sont prêts à tout pour avoir ce qu'on
appelle l'argent pourquoi parce qu'ils
estiment que c'est l'argent qui leur
permet d'exister alors que c'est faux
l'argent n'est qu'un moyen
la vraie richesse de ce qu'on est et ce
qu'on a à donner et moi j'ai décidé
et moi j'ai décidé quelle que soit et et
juste avant de passer à cette étape
c'est à dire que une autre leçon que
j'ai apprise dans la vallée c'est
l'humilité
parce que justement dans le pr dans la
première étape de ma vie j'étais
quelqu'un de gentil tout ça mais en fait
j'étais guindé parce que je n'ai pas
confiance en moi donc j'ai sauvé les
apparences mais quand j'ai appris à
avoir confiance à moi j'ai commencé à
aimer ce qu'on appelle l'humilité je ne
cherche plus à paraître un peu comme la
levure je fais pas de bruit mais je
porte du fruit et c'est ça qui est
important
or ce que je voudrais dire à quelqu'un
ici ce que je voudrais dire à quelqu'un
ici c'est que la vie en fait on n'est
pas sur cette terre par hasard j'espère
que vous allez trouver mon morceau un
bon on n'est pas sur cette terre par
hasard en fait non tenues ici moi je lis
un peu assimilé à un process de
recrutement en entreprise un directeur
d'entreprise à un besoin
il veut recruter une comptable qu'est-ce
qui fait il lance un appel à
candidatures beaucoup de personnes
postulent ya des entretiens qui s'en
suivait puis sélectionne c'est pareil
dieu que nous priions à un besoin besoin
sur la terre il a peut-être besoin de
quelqu'un qui va aider les orphelins qui
va aider les autres à être à manifester
leur potentiel il lance de la paix
l'entente la candidature donc dans le
temps il alors que l'appel à
candidatures mes parents donc ont vu ce
qu'ils ont fait ce qu'ils devaient faire
200 millions de spermatozoïdes sont
sortis pour les féconder l'ovule jeudi
celle qui a été sélectionné donc je suis
venu sur cette terre pour cette vision
pour une vision donc on n'est pas ici
par hasard parce que quand vous sortez
de chez vous sur le matin vous prenez
votre voiture et que vous tournez dans
abidjan panne sèche d'essence un avion
qui décolle qui sait pas où vivent 1
élise se crasher par contre votre
attitude n'est pas la même quand vous
savez où vous partez vous savez que vous
êtes au bureau à 8 heures je vous assure
vous ne perdez pas votre temps à
discuter avec tout ce que vous croisez
sur votre route vous avez un objectif
vous prenez votre voiture vous êtes au
bureau fait photos que vous revenez
c'est pour ça qu'il faut avoir une
vision c'est la vision qui décide dit
qu'ils pardon qui définit la destination
et pour terminer ce que je voudrais dire
c'est qu'aujourd'hui moi mon étoile
polaire comme je dis c'est être coach en
développement personnel cdd surtout les
jeunes parce qu'aujourd'hui j'ai été
écoeurée tangente en conçut rentré de
france et que j'ai entendu des jeunes
diplômés aux abords des routes en train
de gérer des cabines téléphoniques ce
moment j'ai discuté avec eux et les
excuses qui me donne c'est que bon ils
connaissent personne n'y a personne pour
les aider et tout est donc bon en
attendant que quelqu'un veuille bien les
aider je dis mais enfin vous êtes partis
à l'école quand même vous avez un
diplôme mais c'est là que j'ai compris
que justement c'est pas notre diplôme
qui nous fait c'est notre vision qui
nous fait ces particules le diplôme
n'est fait moyen
il nous permet d'arriver quelque part
mais c'est pas le diplôme qui nous fait
donc j'ai eu vraiment ce cette passion
là pour aider cette jeunesse là pour
qu'il puisse aller de l'avant en
trouvant chacun ce qui fait leur
individualité ce qu'ils pourront
apporter au monde et c'est ce qui fera
de nous de vous de véritables leaders
parce qu'en fait le véritable leader
c'est pas celui qui qui commande est ou
non le leader c'est celui qui sert celui
qui le donne celui qui a quelque chose à
apporter
vous avez les moyens vous avez à coeur
d'aider les pauvres fait le ca sera
votre leadership et ses dents ça que
vous allez cesser ce sera le chemin en
fait que vous utiliserez pour aller au
sommet cela pas autre chose et si tout
le monde comprenait ça si par exemple
les entreprises avaient en leur sein
d'eads et coach en développement
personnel des motivateurs détecteur de
talents de talent comme moi il ferait de
bons recrutements
il fera de bons recrutements d'une part
donc comme ils ont ils auraient fait de
bons recrutements chacun serait à sa
place non je vous assure que les faux
litige qui a dans les entreprises des
jalousies inutiles elles disparaîtront à
ce que chacun est dans son environnement
il est comme un poisson dans l'eau
il n'a pas besoin d'aller regarder ce
que l'autre fait elle jaloux de l'autre
mais il veut collaborer pour pouvoir
mieux faire avancer parce que le leader
c'est celui là
ils se connaissent on peut tout mon
talent il devient il développe une
expertise et collaborent pour faire
avancer les choses et aujourd'hui la
côte d'ivoire en a besoin
la côte d'ivoire a besoin de jeunes
hommes deux jeunes dames le chômage dont
on parle c'est pas l'état qui va le
résoudre ce sont les jeunes c'est nous
qui sommes ici et d'autres personnes
peut-être même qu'ils le savent pas
qu'ils vont résoudre ce problème de
chômage parce que à mon avis je peux
peut-être me tromper la solution se
trouve certainement dans
l'entreprenariat jeune dont je voudrais
vraiment vous remercier et vous invitez
vraiment à vous poser trois questions
qui suis-je où je vais et qui
m'accompagne ça je parle à mes amis
amies femmes
voilà qui aspirent au mariage qui non
celles qui sont pas encore mariées avant
de demander qui va vous accompagner
trouver d'abord qui vous êtes
parce que vous n'allez pas vous réalisez
à travers un mariage c'est ce que je
croyais je pensais que le fait de me
marie hélène permettent d'être quelqu'un
mais j'ai aligné échec sur échec
aujourd'hui je sais que il faut d'abord
que j'existe par moi-même pour pouvoir
mieux accompagner mon partenaire vers
une destinée
si on aura eu en commun je vous remercie